bonsoir et bienvenue pour votre journal
quotidien d'information locale il est 18
heures si vous nous rejoignez en direct
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce 17
février les principaux titres ils sont
226 à se présenter devant les électeurs
yvelinois les listes en vue des
élections départementales de mars validé
par la préfecture nous ferons le point
dans un instant voté aujourd'hui la loi
macron provoque aussi la colère des
auto-écoles plusieurs des dispositions
et qui a trop le syndicat unique dont le
président est installé dans les yvelines
cela va à l'encontre de l'économie du
social et de la sécurité routière et
puis invité le comte paul de la panouse
fondateur du parc zoologique de thoiry
son établissement ouvre à nouveau ses
portes après la trêve hivernale ce qui a
changé ses ambitions il sera tout à
l'heure sur ce plateau pour débuter nous
sommes donc en ligne avec que philippe
colombani le président installé dans les
yvelines de l'unique bonsoir à vous
l'unic union nationale des indépendants
de la conduite les auto écoles qui
protestent toujours contre les nouvelles
dispositions contenues dans la loi mâcon
qui vise à libéraliser la profession la
loi était votée aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée il combat ni vous avez le
sentiment de ne pas avoir été entendue
finalement pendant les débats à
l'assemblée rien n'a changé entre la
proposition est ce qui a été voté
je ne dirais pas ça le fait que l hôtel
et développer quand même par le 49-3 ce
qui veut dire que ce gouvernement
aujourd'hui n'a pas la certitude d'avoir
la majorité sur cette loi donc ça veut
dire quand même que il ya beaucoup de
députés qui nous en fait en outre en vue
je dirais le contraire - et que monsieur
mâcon aujourd'hui s'est pris une claque
ce qui veut dire quoi ce qui veut dire
que la suite et que le sénat va être en
position de force aussi pour amender la
loi et que évidemment il va falloir
revenir à un moment à l'assemblée
nationale et puis elle allait la donne
la donne ne fera pas la même pas trop
froid on peut pas l'utiliser tous les
jours non plus donc d'abord un il faudra
que vous avez confiance donc je pense
qu'il aura ou alors on fera taire et
vend dans une crise politique et ce sera
un autre débat mais je pense que les
actions des autres écoles comme d'autres
professions d'ailleurs ont porté leurs
fruits que certains députés commencent à
comprendre qu'il ya des choses en fait
toile attirant
dangereux et
voilà justement quels sont les points
qui aujourd'hui vous pose toujours
problème est que vous espérez donc voir
modifié à l'avenir notamment peut-être
avait râlé auprès du sénat la
combinaison mois par la position de
notre syndicat est très claire les
retours à l'article 9 de la loi du
projet de loi initial avec la rédaction
du projet de loi initial c'est à dire il
y avait la privatisation des gamins code
la privatisation du groupe lourd pour
tout ce qui est diplômé professionnels
et trois bars parce que aussi bien à
l'elysée que ailleurs on nous avait
promis sur rien pour les autres écoles
dans la loi macron que c'était une
réforme qui est en discussion et
précieux 16 heures donc j'ai envie de
dire raison de plus pour
enfoncer le clou rien dans la loi ma
chrome sur mac on doit reculer et je
pense qu'il reculera patron n'a pas fini
d'en parler et on va pas lâcher le
morceau mais moi je suis pour qu'on
revienne à l'article 9 initial après le
reste il ya des dangers qu'ils sont des
anges et qui dépasse largement le cadre
de la profession monsieur battre on veut
libéraliser complètement là
le métier avec des moniteurs
indépendants qui auront très peu de
cotisations sociales à payer puisque
l'on sait qu'un auto-entrepreneur quand
même pas super bien protégés et la page
après ça tout simplement la
paupérisation d'une profession qu'est-ce
qui le soutient malgré tout la récent
mais notre profession est ce qu'il ne
faut pas malgré tout attendre on ne dit
pas qu'il faut pas la réforme et on dit
il faut pas la réforme est comme ça
monsieur veut réformer la profession
nous étions en train de le faire avec
monsieur 4,9
et nous avons nous avions bien avancé et
sauf que monsieur peur il s'est fait
éjecter par monsieur macron deux forces
bon j'étais un coup d'état quelques
parades ou d'état qui lui a pris il y
apprit son dossier ce que l'on nous
disons nous c'est que une libéralisation
complète et ça dépasse largement le
cadre du métier les français doivent le
comprendre ça quand on veut aller vers
de l'auto entreprenariat à outrance
l'arrêt à la commande la conséquence de
tout ça c'est l'individualisme à
outrance est à dire des travailleurs qui
sont indépendantes qu'on peut jeter les
côtes du travail on peut jeter le
contrat de travail on peut jeter des
prix des biens n'a plus besoin on a
réglé le problème des retraites puisque
c'est l'individualisme et chacun doit
cotiser de sa poche à la retraite ben
voilà c'est fait monsieur max et pas
autre chose voilà nous thème social qui
nous propose et moi j'ai dit que non
parce que c'est la dépression du système
social de répartition et nutrition du
système français de solidarité est alors
évidemment quand les coups nous allons
poursuivre notre combat on vous allez
poursuivre votre combien on l'a bien
compris en tout cas ce soir vous étiez
mobiliser d'ailleurs ce matin encore
vous avait déclamé l'oraison funèbre de
l'éducation routière c'est
vrai j'ai surtout rappelé la trahison de
mode macro député broc et avaries
concertation et à coups d'amendements
de la ville ont totalement détruit la
réglementation des professions merci
philippe président du syndicat unique
les auto-écoles votre syndicat en colère
on l'a bien compris après le vote de
macron aujourd'hui mais qui repassera
encore devant à les assembler pour une
validation définitive vous allez donc
rester mobilisés merci à vous
l'actualité de ce 17 février c'est aussi
en politique la publication des listes
des candidats qui se présentent dans les
yvelines pour les élections
départementales scrutin 22 et 29 mars
ils sont 226 inscrit à se présenter
devant les électeurs
ils sont 226 226 à prétendre à un poste
de conseiller départemental des yvelines
l'élection se déroulera les 22 et 29
mars chaque électeur de chacun des 21
cantons votre en réalité pour un binôme
hommes femmes la droite déjà largement
majoritaire entend rester premier parti
des yvelines et a donc sceller son
alliance avec les centristes de l'udf
pendant que la gauche part divisée que
le front national entend jouer les
trouble-fête en se présentant c'est une
première dans toute les yvelines dans le
détail sur le secteur de saint quentin
on retrouve sur le canton de montigny le
bretonneux le président de
l'agglomération michel laugier divers
droite associé à laurence trochut de
l'ump
le sortant socialiste françois de ligne
et maire de guyancourt fait alliance
avec la responsable départementale du ps
sandrine grands groupes un duel qui sera
particulièrement suivie l'absence
d'union à gauche avec une liste europe
écologie les verts front de gauche sera
peut-être déterminant la droite entend
réaliser le grand chelem sur ces
élections de l'aveu du président sortant
pierre bédier et pour cela elle n'hésite
pas à envoyer des élus de premier plan
ainsi jean michel fourgous maire ump
d'elancourt et anne capio sa deuxième
adjointe vont tenter de ravir le canton
de trappage anne-marie divers gauche et
alain ajaj mère-commune east de la
verrière qui lui n'a pas reçu le soutien
de son parti qui préfèrent l'alliance
avec europe ecologie les verts
candidature surprise celle du directeur
du collège musulman de saint quentin en
yvelines slimane busan à un cas atypique
sur le canton de maurepas ce sont deux
conseillers sortants qui se font face en
raison du redécoupage imposées par
l'état ismaila vannes ps face à yves
vandewalle ump chacun avec son binôme
christine merci adjointe à magny les
hameaux et alexandra rosetti maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux là aussi fortes
divisions à gauche entre l'alliance
écologiste communiste et la présence du
candidat malheureux aux dernières
municipales à maurepas michel chat pas
sûr plaisir à présent division des
écologistes et des communistes présence
du front national présence de debout la
france et rivalités ps pas moins de six
listes l'élu départemental sortant le
socialiste jean michel gourdon a décidé
de ne pas se représenter enfin sur le
canton de saint cyr l'école jean
philippe mallet brigue un nouveau mandat
avec la socialiste fabienne jargon bilbo
mais après avoir emporté la mairie de
bois d'arcy l'ump philippe benassaya
aimerait renforcer son implantation sur
le secteur avec l'aide de l'ue dit sonia
bros ces listes de candidats restent
néanmoins provisoire le ministère de
l'intérieur doit encore se prononcer sur
leur validité
ils sont 220 et puis appui politique un
toujours à la verrière on se satisfait
de l'accord trouvé avec le ministère de
l'éducation nationale afin de maintenir
les moyens accordés aux zones
prioritaires une convention sera bien
signer afin de maintenir des effectifs
limités dans les classes avec des aides
financières et humaines toujours
importante un accord qui fait suite à
plusieurs mois de mobilisation de la
population et des responsables
politiques après l'annoncé d'un rodez
coupage nationale du réseau d'éducation
prioritaire qui exclurait donc de fait
cette commune
le gouvernement vient d'officialiser le
contrat de plan état région hier
après-midi manuel valls premier ministre
et jean paul huchon président de l'île
de france ont signé un accord de prêt de
7 milliards d'euros sur cinq ans les
précisions avec nos confrères de votv
7,3 milliards d'euros pour les projets
de la région ile de france sur les 6
prochaines années c'est le montant total
du contrat de plan etat-région signé ce
lundi après midi par le premier ministre
manuel valls et jean paul huchon conseil
régional une somme qui sera
essentiellement investis dans les
transports à hauteur de 5,2 milliards au
programme la modernisation du réseau de
rer le prolongement d'eole vers mantes
la jolie et le bouclage du plan tramway
en réalité on peut dire que
je dis pas que le travail est fini c'est
loin d'être le cas mais on dispose
sécurité absolue en matière
d'investissements transport usa
franchement c'est le résultat bien sûr
de négociation et même parfois de
bagarre avec gouvernement avec bercy et
kia mais le premier ministre a vraiment
carrément
si je veux dire appuyé sur le sujet à
noter que ce contrat est à régions
concernent aussi l'enseignement
supérieur l'innovation l'emploi la
transition écologique lors du vote du
projet de contrat survenu la semaine
dernière ps et europe ecologie les verts
avaient voté pour le front de gauche et
les centristes de l'udf s'étaient
abstenus l'ump avait voté contre les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste se dérouler cette semaine au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines j
moins un avant le début de la
compétition objectif pour les sprinteurs
tricolores remporter au moins cinq
médailles et se classer parmi les plus
titrés les nations les plus titrées de
la compétition michael et demi d'euros
yolaine thorez ont rencontré vincent
jacquey c'est le directeur technique
nationale du cyclisme
mais sam avec vincent jacquet directeur
technique national ensemble nous allons
parler de l'équipe de france et des
championnats du monde sur piste alors
est ce que vous êtes prêt pour ces
championnats du monde sur piste parler
parce que j'apprécie oui les athlètes
sont prêts et effectivement ça fait déjà
quelques temps que la pression monte
effectivement ça fait maintenant deux
mois plus de deux mois qu'on a en vase
clos et je suis ta la dernière du de
coupe du monde de cali il est clair
qu'aujourd'hui les athlètes ont besoin
de rentrer sur cette piste et ont besoin
d'en découdre les compétitions vont
bientôt arriver et très concrètement les
athlètes seront prêts et quels sont les
objectifs l'objectif de chaque athlète
c'est de gagner évidemment un mais
derrière ça on a effectivement une
dynamique qui va se lancer dès le
mercredi soir sur la vitesse par équipe
sur laquelle on souhaite le plus beau la
plus belle des médailles derrière ça on
a on a quand même des potentiels de
quatre à cinq médailles sur les
championnats du monde qui nous
paraissent non pas ambitieux mais
raisonnable à voir et donc il faudra
assurer tout de suite les premières
courses ah oui et là ça va danser la
dynamique 1 les premières finales c'est
mercredi encore une fois sur sur la
vitesse par équipes qui est l'un de nos
points forts effectivement on a
travaillé puis depuis un certain nombre
de mois à restaurer la confiance de
cette équipe l'envié l'ambition et les
trois athlètes sont prêts et en termes
de médailles vous comptez sur des
sprinteurs en particulier alors bon bah
vitesse par équipes évidemment là
l'équipe qui est présenté avec grégory
kevin et et michael on leur souhaite
lors évidemment et puis après sur la
vitesse individuelle tout peut se jouer
avec de très bons compétiteurs comme
gorille comme michael comme campagne
effectivement derrière on a on a au
chili le plus françois pervis qui nous
permet sur notre territoire de pouvoir
défendre le titre de champion du monde
quelle richesse je fais un dtn qui n'ont
pas qui a l'embarras du choix mais qui a
une densité en termes de sprinteurs qui
était très intéressante et ça serait un
véritable échec si vous n'arrivez à papa
a remporté une seule médaille
effectivement effectivement on est chez
nous on s'est préparé on a beaucoup
travaillé tant sur le sprint que sur
l'endurance ce serait une grosse
contre-performance de ne pas ramené de
médaille de ces championnats du monde
tout en sachant que pour nous l'objectif
avoué il est à rio ici c'est un gros
point de passage un gros point
d'évaluation de savoir où est-ce qu'on
en ait pour s'étalonner face aux
meilleurs mondiaux on est chez nous donc
on compte bien ramener la médaille et
merci à vous à vincent jacquet les
championnats du monde sur piste au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
du 18 au 22 février et les mondiaux bien
sûr à suivre sur tv fil 78 l'invité
aujourd'hui le comte paul de la panouse
bonsoir et bienvenue en plateau pour
évoquer la réouverture de votre parc de
thoiry réouverture depuis le 14 février
tout s'est bien passé dont la reprise
les visiteurs étaient au rendez vous on
va parler des nouveautés tout d'abord du
parquet en lui-même depuis l ouverture
1968 vous avez toujours voulu renouveler
l'expérience pour les visiteurs il faut
se renouveler à chaque fois il faut se
renouveler les mises en scène et l'avoir
en rêve toujours d'avoir l'espace qu'on
n'a pas encore
et donc sur toutes mes enfants de succès
dès que ma fille a des rêves petits et
grands dans le petit on a des dents
larges des petites bêtes il ya des
animaux qui sont bien plus rares que les
dragons de komodo et le preneur parce
qu'ils sont des espèces la deux qui
n'existe plus en milieu naturel et qu'on
élève chez nous comme les écarts ou tu
pars tu là qui sait on a des iguanes des
îles fidji qui sans feu vert
phosphorescent sur verre
extraordinaire les couleurs étonnantes
et puis on va avoir le criquet ducrocq
votre espèce extrêmement menacée en
france alors comment vous faites
justement pour déjà trouvé ces espèces
réussir à les obtenir et puis rester au
fait tu peux on va dire de cette
actualité là aussi vous surveiller en
permanence et votre rôle vous l'avez dit
vous avez passé la main aussi oui donc
maintenant en tant que co fondateur du
parc vous avez regarde un petit peu
extérieur et vous vous intervenez j'ai
tout le plaisir je suis le premier
visiteur elle n'est pas ce que tu peux
faire maintenant voilà presque oublié
que le plaisir de temps en temps j'ai
d'un point à profil
voir les animaux pape alors je vois des
bêtes entre autres
il arrive et vous restez vous surveiller
en permanence commencent à évoluer pour
moi je n'ai pas apprécié comment ça
évolue j'ai rien ne surveiller les
équipes son comble tout renouveler
jeunes très dynamique alors vous dites
comment les obtient s'il ya des espèces
pour lesquelles
large des petites bêtes est tellement
scientifique et
et c'est une formule à dire à toyer bon
gars allez les lions tunnel de verre des
lions qui mènera les tigres ça s'est
passé c'est facile à gérer car
quand on a la méthode mais
c'est de la grosse mécanique qui l'on
peut dire même les ailes france
maîtrisent bien et bon par contre large
des petites bêtes c'est celle là la
bonne reproduction c'est fait merci
appelé rapport du jour
les ours vient quasiment rien parce
qu'ils se débrouillent tout seuls et
creusent leur terrier et montrent aux
arts binage rien à dire
il ya ça le rapport sur la paire qu'en
voiture et il ya ça deux rapports sur
l'arche des petites bêtes parce que
terrarium par terrarium
c'est faux que cela soit réglé ni quel
point de vue et puis albi nouveau
vivarium donc a été complètement rénové
je vous propose justement je vous
interromps mais je propose aux
téléspectateurs de s'y rendre justement
danse vivarium puisque nous sommes allés
voir sur place à quoi elle ressemblait
puis on va continuer à échanger ensemble
tout nouveau tout beau voici les bras kg
fussent face hiatus ce couple d'iguane
des îles fidji n'en est pas vraiment un
car ils sont frère et soeur cathy gibeau
vétérinaire aux charges des reptiles
nous fait découvrir cette espèce rare
ils sont arrivés il ya une quinzaine de
jours
du zoo de vienne en autriche viennent va
nous échanger l'un ou l'autre
parce qu'ils attendent justement de deux
nouveaux gènes d'une autre ligne et est
donc ça permettra là de faire des
échanges dans leur habitat naturel ces
petits reptiles longue de 80 cm sont
menacés par la déforestation et la
destruction de leur habitat par l'homme
ici ils peuvent profiter des terrariums
rénové nouvelle décoration mais surtout
nouvel éclairage et ce ne sont pas les
warrants qui vont s'en plaindre c'est
toute une rampe au de néons ultra violet
donc qui sont en fait situé au dessus du
rocher qui est près de la fenêtre donc
c'est un endroit où il aime bien
ce prélat s'est surtout quand il ya des
rayons de soleil à l'extérieur qui tape
sur la fenêtre dont qui sent la chaleur
qui a porté par le soleil quand même à
travers la fenêtre et donc on a profité
de ce point où il aime bien resté
allongé pour justement elle est
positionnée judicieusement les uv au
dessus et même les visiteurs n'ont pas
été oubliés
là vous avez un tronc de séquoia qui
était dans le parc c'est ainsi qu'au ya
qui était très âgé et qui devait toute
façon est abattu donc on en a profité
pour le recycler en banc pour pour nos
visiteurs tous les réaménagements de la
galerie ont été réalisés avec du bois
provenant de la forêt de thoiry un petit
coup de jeune bienvenu le vivarium
n'avait subi aucune transformation
depuis son ouverture en 98
on vient de voir son vivarium tout
nouveau ou du commando qui sont d'un
rarissime parce qu'elle va montrent que
dragon de komodo sont des parents ils
n'ont pas évolué depuis les dinosaures
et les warrants sont les ancêtres des
serpents c'est plus grand que les arts
au monde qui fait trois mètres de long
adultes et 150 kg 4 ap des chevaux des
sangliers quelquefois des hommes
et qui survivent dans 3 2 il une
presqu'île dont la superficie totale est
le septième du département des yvelines
et ceci depuis 65 millions d'années ils
survivent que là pour dire la fragilité
et la rareté de cette espèce justement
c'est votre rôle aussi au parc
zoologique ce parc de thoiry c'était
votre volonté depuis le début de
protéger ces espèces aussi doit restée
très simple car et c'est le château est
un vaisseau à voyager dans le temps et
d'ailleurs enfin une expo à faire une
expo nous on demande aux visiteurs
s'étaient discours participative nous
avons vu il ya cinquante ans le château
j'ai ouvert il ya 50 ans avec
l'autorisation de mes parents j'ai
ouvert le château au public pour lui
donner une fonction sociale par une
activité culturelle donc on demande aux
gens qui ont des souvenirs de thoiry un
ticket des photos et autres de nous les
amener en fera des copies et on les
mettra pour préparer le musée amusé pour
les 50 ans qui sont en 2018 mais on
commence maintenant on fait donc un jeu
là dessus et alors le château ta vie
soit voyager dans le temps avec quatre
cent mille pièces d'archivés des meubles
et des objets d'art mais pour sauver le
vaisseau a voyagé dans le temps libre
une arche de noé donc les animaux sauve
le château et le château et les jardins
s'ouvrent les animaux en leur offrant de
grands espaces ce qu'on a la chance
d'avoir un grand domaine près de 400
hectares et on en utilise actuellement
150 qui fait qu'on offre aux animaux et
cie espace commun des pailles à se faire
marcher un peu plus les gens mais comme
il ya des points forts comme le tunnel
des lions la réplique bête on arrive à a
rythmé la visite et puis on passe la
journée ici tout est sur cette
protection des animaux juste moyen des
partenariats qui s'engagent vous êtes
comme comment vous travaillez pour la
protection des plus que des partenariats
vous allez 360 espèces qui sont en
programme européen d'élevage et dons via
le hasard pied l'association européenne
pour chaque espèce qui a programmé un
coordinateur et c'est lui qui dit à bas
le bébé panda roux qui est né à thoiry
doit aller à berlin votre femme elle a
eu trop de petits maintenant la série
sinon ça
génétiquement elle sera pour présenter
donc vous envoyez votre jeu mais là des
parcs sont pas très bien encore comment
les élever et nous on vous envoie une
reproductrices puisque vous vous savez
les reproduire bon c'est comme ça que ça
se passe face à cette obligation assez
énorme et puis maintenant il fait une
quarantaine et d'ailleurs c'est là mais
bien interroger et dernière fois sur la
tva c'est là où je n'étais pas très
content parce que tu as mangé allait
venir parce que la tv elle a augmenté
vous êtes innocent la tow la dernière
fois pour nous et brian les difficultés
avec par exemple les cirques 1 qui paye
est monté à que vous étiez des
conditions d'accueil pour ces animaux du
canada
nous avons trois obligations qui sont
venus par l'europe reprises par les
l'initiation françaises vont reproduire
leur protéger les espèces chaque
programme chaque fois qu'il ya un
progrès faits dans un parc zoologique on
impose aux autres donc il ya là des
remises en norme perpétuelle qui coûte
très cher
il y a une vision pédagogique que nous
remplissons et donc
une mission scientifique avec rapport au
préfet tous les trois ans de ce qu'ils
ont fait ou pas en mission sont épais
dans trois missions d'intérêt général
pour ça on avait une tva à taux réduit à
5,5 on l'a monté à 10 et on a redescendu
aussi requis ni micky qui garde des
animaux alors j'ai rien contre le cirque
si ce n'est que pour certains animaux
les conditions sont quand même
scandaleuse parce que ils n'ont
absolument pas les obligations que nous
avons donc le confort des animaux et -
la sécurité j'en parle pas nous avons
des normes de sécurité complète et en
plus depuis un an nous avons été obligés
de construire ce que le public ne voit
pas notamment été obligés de construire
une quarantaine là c'est la législation
européenne
le cirque balade des animaux partout ça
n'avait pas du tout été entendu
aujourd'hui encore va t
on se bat bing auprès des députés des et
louis et certains comme les oies mon
nous aussi très gentiment ils ont promis
de ce qu'ils voulaient et puis au moment
des votes à banon
y a plus de sous donc voilà on laisse
fiscalement on crée des injustices
voilà
d'autant plus que nous ne sommes pas
subventionnés donc on paye des impôts
c'est ça mais aujourd'hui en péril le
parc non seulement nous avons ici la
rive mais en plus on fait face à
l'ouverture de 20 celles qui est a
investi en argent en fait public vingt
fois notre chiffre d'affaires donc au
niveau même au niveau européen c'est
c'est de la concurrence déloyale mais ça
fait rien on fait quand même parce que
nous avons une chose que les autres
n'ont pas un espace on a un très bel
espace donc les animaux ils expriment
leur comportement les gens peuvent y
passer la journée française de ce fait
d'ailleurs on a des fidèles le passeport
touahri ou pour le prix de deux entrées
on peut venir de deux trois entrées on
peut venir tous les jours toute l'année
pendant 200 ans après un jour et en
expansion comme cela c'est par des
laquais les vrais fidèles qui leur vient
de révéler un millier famille
je vous propose parce qu'on est pris par
le temps de conclure cet entretien avec
notre question du jour micro-trottoir
habituel dans ce journal notre question
du jour qu'à l'image que pensez vous de
ce parc de thoiry quelques réponses
devant des sabots fille mais voit c'est
pas mal pas mal d'animaux pas mal de
petites aventures affaires pour les
enfants c'est juste que c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal a conseillé je pense que
c'est un bon saut après mois les hausses
et pas toujours le font les meilleurs
endroits j'aime pas trop ce à quoi
préfère quand les animaux y sont dans
l'avènement leur milieu naturel mais vu
des zèbres
et des choses bien des lions des
hippopotames stévia c'est une réserve
assez grande où les animaux sont en
liberté donc je pense que c'est une
bonne réserve je trouve ça magnifique je
allé plusieurs fois d'ailleurs parce que
les amis les animaux sont quand même en
liberté quelques pages on les voit
beaucoup mieux qu'ailleurs donc
voilà j'ai c'est super pour les enfants
et même pour ceux qui sont pas des
enfants quoi pour les petits pour les
bancs tout le monde apprécie votre parc
c'est plutôt une bonne note pour finir
je suis le premier visiteur de ce parc
sera oui merci beaucoup d'être venu sur
ce plateau encore pour nous parler de ce
parc de thoiry qui a réouvert ses portes
pour une nouvelle saison merci encore à
vous
retour au xviie siècle au château de
versailles à présent une série diffusée
l'automne prochain sur canal+ est
actuellement en tournage versa et
revient sur la vie du jeune roi à la fin
d année 760 sur sa bataille pour imposer
son pouvoir et sur la construction du
château avec ses milliers de visiteurs
chaque jour le château de versailles
s'est adaptée dès lundi lors du jour de
fermeture pour recevoir les équipes de
tournage il faut une coordination
exceptionnelle pour que le château de
versailles soit disponible vide ouvert
et puisse accueillir un tournage comme
ça qu'on n'est pas au milieu du tournage
quelqu'un qui traverse la cour au
mauvais moment ça n'est pas possible
lorsqu'on fait des films et nous
reviendrons bien sûr sur ce tournage au
cours d'un long reportage dans notre
édition de demain dès 18 heures en
direct puisque c'est la fin de ce
journal est votre soirée à présent sur
tv fils c'est avec catherine zola tôt
pour un nouveau 7,8 société consacrée au
harcèlement à l'école très bonne soirée